welcome back to las vegas now findlay
toyota has incredible bonds and
partnerships
with the las vegas community take a look
[Music]
here we are at findlay toyota and john
barr you have so many great partnerships
with people
and businesses in the community what is
so special about your partnership with
the las vegas lights football club
what's so special i mean it's football
the real
football so i'm so excited i mean you've
got manchester united you've got real
madrid
now you've got the las vegas lights john
i love it
brett why is the partnership so special
to you jesse what kind of question is
that john barr and philly toyota
they are las vegas they're for las vegas
by las vegas
they support all the local teams they
are so part of this community and john's
at all of our games it was no doubt
viva lights viva you know what stop
come with me i want to show you
something
brent this is amazing we look fantastic
[Applause]
coach what are you doing here huge
soccer fan go knights go
go lights go
[Applause]
these jerseys are beautiful look good
feel good play good jc
what's the best part of soccer score the
goal and what do we do when we score
goals
is this one all that all the players all
season long all the players all the fans
we're celebrating our goals with our
shirt surf and a big john barr's face
it's going to be amazing
what can we expect on june 5th at the
homeowner june 5th we're going to have a
downtown las vegas soccer party it's
only ten dollars come one come on it's
going to be a blast
now johnny you have something special
playing for the fans this season we do
the fans
the team the city and especially
the opposition
[Applause]
you guys both look the part now how
about we go outside and see if you guys
can play the part i got a little
competition for you let's do it all
right
[Music]
hey guys really simple competition which
of the two of you can kick the bulb in
the back of the new rav4
all right jc let's see what you got kick
it
hey jc with the foot like that you're
not gonna be playing for us on june
finley toyota is located in henderson at
the valley auto mall call them at
702-566-2500
and find them online at finleytoyota.com